c'était Ouigour mécanique d'un génocide
annoncé un film une alerte j'ai envie de
dire lancé par vous Éric d'bré bonjour
merci beaucoup de participer à la Zone
d'Éducation documentaire alors vous nous
expliquerez entre autres dans quelles
conditions vous avez réalisé ce film à
vos côté on accueille Valérie Nick
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
politologue chercheuse en géopolitique
spécialiste de la Chine et de l'Asie du
Sud-Est alors vous allez pouvoir tous
les deux évidemment nous éclairer sur la
situation des G grâce au travail au très
grand travail de la classe de 3e du
collège le Luzard bonjour les élèves
bonjour merci beaucoup d'avoir travaillé
sur sur ce film je sais que vous avez
plein de questions à poser à nos invités
mais juste avant de commencer je voulais
d'abord savoir qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé quelle pensée vous a traversé
quand vous avez vu ce documentaire
est-ce qu'il y a des séquences qui vous
ont choqué est-ce que vous avez pu tout
regarder dites-moi comme ça ouais je dis
bah quand j'ai vu quand on a terminé de
regarder le documentaire bah en soit ça
m'a choqué ou en voyant des enfants
séparés de leur famille leur famille à
cause des gouver des gouvernements tout
ça parce qu'ils sont pas de la même
religion moi ce qui m'a choqué c'est les
Témo les témoignages de torture des des
victimes ça ça m'a choqué je me demande
comment ils ont ils ont pu leur faire ça
ce qui m'a
choqué c'était les les
photos de stérilisation moi c'est le
moment où on voit dans le un musée en
Turquie il nous montre comment ils
étaient torturés ouais bien sûr bien sûr
h est-ce que vous aviez déjà entendu
parler de la situation des ougours avant
de regarder ce film non qui en avait
déjà entendu parler lever la main ça
fait pas
beaucoup très peu comment vous expliquez
ça comment vous expliquez le fait que
c'est grâce à ce documentaire que vous
avez
réaliser ce qui se passait là-bas moi je
trouve que c'est une information qu'il
faut beaucoup partager parce que si
notre classe on a décou enfin la plupart
de nos classes on l' découvert grâce à à
nos cours et Ben et que c'est important
aussi parce
que c'est un crime moi je pense qu'il
faudrait plus le partager bien sûr l tu
voulais rajouter quelque chose faut plus
médiatiser de sujet ouais et maintenant
je vous propose de passer à vos
questions et on commence tout de suite
avec K pour Éric dabr comment avez-vous
pu vous rendre de si nombreuses fois au
St Jong alors que la région est
présentée comme quasiment
inaccessible alors c'est c'est une
question qu'on pose souvent j'y suis
allé à chaque fois en tant que
touriste la première fois c'était il y a
25 ans c'était pas très très compliqué
et chaque année c'était plus plus
difficile donc bah j'ai dû imaginer des
des stratagèmes soit je passais par
Pékin soit par d'autres d'autres front
mais chaque année c'était plus difficile
pour Éric darbr comment avez-vous obtenu
l'ensemble de ces informations et de ces
images alors j'ai obtenu toutes ces
informations grâce au lien de confiance
que j'ai avec l'opposition Ouigour et et
au victime qui savent
que qui que je ne les trahirai pas
et et que la médiatisation de leur de
leur souffrance de leur de leur
cas peut-être pourra forcer la Chine
éventuellement à à stopper euh ce
drame Nathan pour Éric dabr avez-vous
réalisé euh ce documentaire euh seul ù
étiez-vous accompagné
d'autres
personnes euh tel qu'un caméraman ou ou
un traducteur alors en effet euh pour
celui-là j'étais accompagné d'un
caméraman un chef opérateur
et comme tu as pu le voir dans mon
documentaire je suis allé dans plusieurs
pays et la plupart du temps c'était on
pouvait discuter en anglais donc ça je
pouvais le faire tout seul et puis quand
c'était en langue Ouigour je faisais
appel à un
interprète Joakim pour Valérie Nick de
quelle nationalité se rvendi que les
Ouigour et à quelle nation se sentent-il
appartenir en fait les Ouigours donc se
revendiquent aujourd'hui de la
nationalité Ouigour qui est une des
minorités nationales reconnues en
République populaire de Chine même si
évidemment ils sont soumis à énormément
de répressions mais en fait c'est des
peuples d'origine turqu qui sont très
proches de l'oubékistan qui est une des
républiques à côté du sing Tiang donc
leur culture en fait ils sont de culture
turque et le mot Ouigour lui-même est
relativement récent même si on cherche
des origines plus anciennes et et ce
sont les
Soviétiques donc l'URSS qui existait
avant la Russie qui au début du 20e
siècle ont nommé les minorités et ne
voulaiit absolument pas parler de cette
minorité comme turque parce qu'ils
avaient peur de l'influence de la
Turquie qui était très grande dans cette
région et donc ils ont créé ce ce
concept de Ouigour qui désignait ces
peuples turcophones qui vivaient dans le
bassin du Tarim au stiang ce qu'on
appelait à époque le turquestan oriental
euh c'est une question pour Éric darbré
quel est le but du documentaire
qu'avez-vous cherché à montrer et
pourquoi avez-vous réalisé ce
documentaire en particulier ça fait 25
ans que je travaille sur ce thème sur
cette question et au début je disais au
Ouigour vous allez voir grâce à ce que
je vais publier les choses vont changer
il va y avoir une prise de conscience de
la population des dirigeants et et la
Chine va arrêter et en fait la Chine n'a
pas arrêté et s allé de de pire en pire
et alors qu'aujourd'hui on reconnaît
l'existence d'un
génocide c'est trop tard d'une certaine
manière moi j'aurais voulu qu'ils
interviennent que les dirigeants
interviennent avant que le gocine
n'arrive maintenant qu'il y a des
centaines de milliers d'ouigours
enfermés qu' a des stérilisations qu'on
fait des avortements jusqu'au 7e mois
qu'on force les femmes Ouigours à se
marier avec des Chinois il y a des trucs
vraiment horribles j'ai l'impression
qu'on se réveil et je me suis senti
presque
fautif donc ce documentaire
c'était forme de de de de crit désespoir
en
disant écoutez-les faites faites changer
les choses prenez conscience de ce qui
se passe là-bas c'est ce peuple est en
train de disparaître on t'écoute far
pour Éric dabr comment avez-vous trouvé
les témoins comment êtes-vous rentré en
contact avec eux et comment les
avez-vous protéger alors c'est une très
bonne question et en fait ça c'est fait
naturellement parce que j'ai commencé il
y a 25 ans à travailler sur cette
question et les ougours me connaissent
assez bien même très bien la
l'opposition ougour la diaspora Ouigour
me connaît bien a confiance en moi donc
à chaque fois que je vais vers eux pour
leur dire je veux faire un nouveau
reportage et il préparent ils savent que
je vais protéger mes interlocuteur et
que bah je les mettrai pas en danger
donc ça c'est une première chose grâce à
eux j'ai accès à des à des Ouigours euh
qui ont des choses à dire qui ont des
témoignages forts alors comment je les
ai protégés j'ai plusieurs plusieurs
techniques la première c'est que je ne
filme pas leur visage euh je t'explique
je pourrais très bien filmer leur visage
et ensuite flouter le visage une une
fois que une fois que j'ai fait le
montage mais c'est sans penser que je
pourrais me faire arrêter avant et que
les autorités prennent mes rush prennent
mes images avant que je sorte du pays
alors que si je filme les pieds si je
filme une partie du corps ou même de dos
ou une chaise ils peuvent pas les
reconnaître le seul risque c'est la voie
donc je dois faire quand même attention
à tout donc je cache mes images et je
prends plusieurs niveaux de sécurité
notamment ne pas filmer leur visage on
enchaîne avec Maria c'est ça ah oui pour
é Darb les familles igour et les
réfugiés ont-ils facilement accepté
d'être filmé alors oui parce que souvent
ils sont demandeurs ils ont envie de
témoigner euh ils ont envie de créer
leur souffrance de faire en sorte que le
plus grand nombre soit au courant de ce
qu'ils subissent donc c'est à moi
souvent de de mesurer les conséquen de
leur témoignage si ces personnes qui
vivent maintenant en Allemagne en
Turquie et ailleurs mais qu'ils ont
encore de la famille en Chine au Xing
Kang c'est à moi de dire non parce que
il est possible que les autorités chois
se Veng sur le famille rest là-bas donc
c'est à moi de même si leur témoignage
est fort super intéressant je dois dire
parfois non pour les
[Musique]
protéger les Mo on passé la situation
est resté la même
ne voit plus qu'une option possible
aller en Chine pour enlever sa
femme
moi jeoudis par un petit peu de cette
séquence est-ce que quand vous avez vu
ces images vous êtes mis à sa
place franchement j'aurais
ét parce que moi mlè mère je saurais pas
quoi faire ça veut dire que je me mettre
à sa place je me dit que qu'il doit
tenir le coup est-ce que est-ce que vous
comprenez la démarche de ce papa est-ce
que vous oui dis-moi Len bah oui parce
que il a des il a des enfants et ils
sont privés de leur mère donc du coup
c'est normal qu'il veut récupérer sa
femme oui dis-moi Maria et sa femme
logiquement il l'a aimé et du coup il
trouve que c'est une personne formidable
ou quelque chose comme ça du coup il
veut que ces enfants ils ils apprennent
à la connaître qu'ils l'ont pas connu
longtemps oui ça m'aurait touché parce
que ma mère m'aurait manqué parce que tu
l'aurais soutenu dans sa démarche oui
jeaurais j'aurais soutenu mon père ouais
j'aurais soutenu mais genre j'aurais pas
voulu que mon père il serait il finisse
mal sil se fait s' arrêter ou quelque
chose comme ça on continue avec nitiche
quels ont été les risques ou quels
auraient pu être les risques que vous
encourz à tourner ce
documentaire
je je pense que je ne risque pas
grand-chose le danger c'est c'est pour
mes interlocuteurs moi très
honnêtement si les Chinois si je vais en
Chine et que les Chinois m'arrêtent
c'est quelques jours de prison ça m'est
déjà arrivé et ensuite je suis expulsé
et je n'aurais je ne serai pas torturé
ma famille ne sera pas emprisonnée alors
que mes interlocuteurs oui donc je dois
tout le temps avoir ça à l'esprit vous
êtes déjà réquisitionné du
matériel alors j'ai j'ai effectivement
été
arrêté plusieurs fois et une fois ils
ont ils ont vérifié mes ma caméra et
estce que j'avais
enregistré mais dans ces cas-là j'ai
toujours ce que j'appelle une des un
enregistrement témoins c'est-à-dire que
je fais exprès de filmer comme un
touriste
les les sites les plus intéressants et
je fais en sorte quand je suis arrêté il
faut que je j'aille très vite je change
la la carte mémoire sur ma caméra je
cache celle avec les interviews et je
mets celle avec les
images complètement anodines de de ce
que pourrait faire n'importe quel
touriste et ça m'est arrivé ils ont
vérifier les images et ils n'ont rien
rien trouvé contre moi pourquoi la Chine
colonise t-elle une autre région
chinoise en
fait le S sang en chinois ça veut dire
nouvelle frontière ça dit bien que ça
n'a pas été é incorporé depuis très
longtemps à l'empire de Chine ça remonte
à l'empire de Chine à la fin du 19e
siècle les Chinois n'avent pas la notion
de la frontière c'estàdire que pour
l'empire de Chine tout était la Chine ça
s'appelait sous le ciel l'empereur
dominait le monde il connaissait très
mal le monde extérieur et donc les les
bords de l'Empire ce qu'on appelle les
Franches de l'Empire donc le singang
très loin à l'Ouest ça faisait dans leur
esprit aussi partie de la zone dominée
par l'empereur de Chine en réalité il ne
dominent rien du tout et c'est seulement
à la fin du 19e siècle que tout d'un
coup comme ils ont rencontré les
puissances occidentales les Russes les
Britanniques qui étaient dans le coin
aussi euh la dynastie chinoise ou plutôt
monchou qui dominait à l'époque fin 19e
vraiment presque avant la chute de la
dynastie C bah nous aussi on va avoir
une vraie frontière et ils ont incorporé
officiellement la province du sang mais
ils l'ont jamais véritablement colonisé
donc c'était plus marquer le territoire
face à d'autres empires qui avançaient
également vers l'Est l'Empire
britannique et l'empire des tar on
t'écoute lénny question pour Valérie
Nick qu'est-ce que la Chine reproche au
Ouigour la Chine reproche aux Ouigours
d'exister tout à l'heure quelqu'un
mentionnait le fait que les ougours
étaient c'était très choquant qu'ils
soient réprimés pour leur religion il y
a pas uniquement la religion les
Ouigours sont musulmans effectivement
Sunis mais ils ont aussi une culture
très forte qui n'est pas la culture ran
chinoise qui domine et qui n'est surtout
pas la culture dominante défendue par le
Parti communiste qui est au pouvoir en
Chine aujourd'hui et ce que la Chine
veut réprimer au sintiang comme elle
veut le réprimer au Tibet comme elle le
réprime en Mongolie comme elle le
réprime en Chine contre toutes les
personnes qui ont une veulent mettre en
avant leur leur identité et bien c'est
tout simplement qu'il y ait quelque
chose qui existe qui ne soit pas
totalement contrôlé par le pouvoir en
place c'est-à-dire le Parti communiste
qu qu ont été vos relations avec le
gouvernement et la police chinoise
durant vos déplacements en Chine alors
je n'ai pas de relation avec le
gouvernement je veux surtout pas en
avoir avec la police j'en ai parce que
euh parce que je suis suivi euh et je le
sais je les connais c'est en fait vous
avez tout le temps quelqu'un derrière
vous c'est même pas discret c'est
presque drôle donc vous faites avec et
puis à un moment il se lassent le tout
c'est de les fatiguer donc je passe des
journées entières à à marcher euh à ne
rien faire de spécial et puis à un
moment euh bah il fatigue euh et puis
c'est à ce moment-là où je fais ce que
j'ai à faire rencontrer euh mes
interlocuteurs Léo on t'écoute Valérie
nické que que pense le reste des Chinois
des actes commis au xingjang existe-t-il
une résistance chinoise en fait c'est ça
un des gros problèmes c'est que euh la
population chinoise Hanan est assez peu
euh non pas qu'elle ne soit pas
consciente parce que elle-même est
soumise à une censure et un contrôle
très sévère elles savent très bien que
des choses se passent au sintiang mais
en réalité il y a une forme de
méconnaissance et de relative
indifférence à l'égard de ce qui se
passe au cytian en dehors de cercle très
très petit de groupes de gens très
restreints qui eux luttent d'une manière
globale y compris en prenant en compte
ce qui ce qui se passe au stiang mais
malheureusement pour beaucoup de Chinois
ça reste un sujet de relative
indifférence même chez des dissidents
qui pendant très longtemps n'attachait
pas une grande importance à ces enjeuxlà
est-ce que d'après vous vous pensez que
les houigours veulent être encore
interpante en fait la position des
Ouigours n'était pas de réclamer
l'indépendance mais tout simplement de
voir respecter leur culture leur mode de
vie leur
liberté et donc ça n'est pas vraiment
l'indépendance qu'il demande sauf pour
certains groupe c'est une forme
d'autonomie qui soit beaucoup mieux
reconnu et surtout l'absence la fin de
la répression h oui Jie on t'écoute pour
Valérie Nick quel est le projet de P
Pékin pour le pour le singang quand le
problème des origo sera traité en fait
ce que veut la Chine c'est un contrôle
absolu sur la zone qui est absolument
plus d'opposition et qui est quasiment
une disparition comme on l'a vu sans
doute grâce au documentaire du peuple
wiigour donc il y a une arrivée massive
de chinois Khan qui occupe le terrain
qui qui domine le commerce et puis
progressivement la population Ouigour
soit elle disparaît il y a les campagnes
de stérilisation dont on a parlé soit
elle est assimilé c'est-à-dire que petit
à petit elle va perdre enfin c'est
l'ambition de la de Pékin c'est de
perdre sa langue perdre sa religion
perdre sa culture et de devenir entre
guillemets des Chinois comme les autres
Sania juste là pourbré quelles sont les
conditions de détention dans les
différents camps au xingjang et quelles
sont les conditions de vie d'hygiène et
des
déten alors pour savoir ça il y a on a
très peu de de sources parce que très
peu de de prisonniers ont pu être
libérés et quitter le pays
euh j'en ai rencontré
quelquesuns les conditions sont sont
assez terribles ils sont dans des dans
des cellules à une vingtaine une
trentaine je sais pas une cellule qui
doit faire 15 m² et et par exemple ils
ne peuvent pas être
tous dormir au même moment il n y a pas
la place pour que tous puissent
s'allonger donc ils doivent tourner euh
les conditions c'est que euh en règle
générale ils se lèvent très tôt le matin
ils font un petit peu de d'exercice
après ils récitent des champs à la
gloire de du parti de shijinping le
président et et il y a plein de choses
comme ça et et ils ont aussi souvent des
des prélèvements sanguins ou alors on le
on leur injecte des produits ne savent
pas ce que c'est les femmes pense que
c'est pour les stériliser mais c'est
difficile de le prouver
il et puis ceux qui résistent bah se
font battre les femmes peent les plus
belles femmes souvent se font violer VO
le pire
quoi quelle est la vie d'un Ouigour non
interné alors la vie d'un Ouigour non
interné c'est de vivre dans la peur
euh c'est ne pas savoir
euh ce qui va lui arriver c'est euh un
truc tout bête moi ça je l'ai vu je l'ai
filmé c'est dans la rue vous avez des
contrôles de vos téléphones de vos
smartphon et si la police trouve dans
votre smartphone quelque chose qu'il
estiment être contre le régime ça peut
être une vidéo de l'étranger vous avez
appelé quelqu'un à l'étranger ça veut
dire que vous êtes en relation avec
l'opposition vous avez quelque chose lié
à l'islam ça veut dire que vous êtes un
terroriste islamiste donc tout ça peut
vous valoir un an prison de disparaître
dans un camp de gros gros problèmes donc
ou c'est en permanence la
[Musique]
trouilleour che s parents dans une
petite ville du sud de la
Norvège c'est aussi pour eux qu'elle se
[Musique]
bat
pas c'est
vraiment c'est
vraiment qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
son combat à cette femme
oui Kira elle est très courageuse parce
que même si je pense que elle sait
qu'elle aussi elle peut être en danger
elle fait quand même pour montrer au
monde ce qui arrive à son peuple h HM
dis-moi Lenny bah c'est très normal
parce que tu son peuple et euh c'est
normal qu'elle veut le qu'elle veul le
protéger les défendre hah elle est
courageuse elles se démèent pour les
autres qui sont en danger ouais en fait
c'est une c'est une jeune Ouigour
brillante qui qui le dit très bien elle
était insouciante avant
elle vivait sa vie de de jeune étudiante
elle était Ouigour mais elle se sentait
du monde entier voilà elle était
norvégienne mais elle parlait
parfaitement anglais elle avait la vie
de devant elle elle s'amusait et puis de
temps en temps elle appelait sa
grand-mère qui était restée en Chine qui
était restée au xingang et puis un beau
jour bah sa grand-mère lui a dit non
arrête de nous arrête de de nous appeler
c'est trop dangereux parce qu'il faut
savoir que les téléphones sont écoutés
et là elle a eu ça elle a eu un choc ça
l'a ramené à la réalité d'un seul coup
elle est sortie de sa zone de confort de
son cocon un peu un peu tranquille elle
s'est dit mais
mais le fait que je chis Ouigour
m'impose d'une certaine manière de
d'agir de ne pas être je ne peux pas
être comme quelqu'un d'autre je dois
faire quelque
chose pour le souvenir de ma grand-mère
et puis après pour le souvenir de mon
peuple donc elle s'est engagé là-dedans
et et je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui peut vous parler parce que imaginez
si d'un seul coup il y a une telle
injustice pouvez plus parler à quelqu'un
de votre famille parce que parce qu'il
n'a rien fait mais parce que il est
différent bah peut-être que vous aussi
vous vous vous poseriez même plus la
question question est-ce que je prends
des risques ou pas j'irai peut-être que
c'est je sais pas si c'est le cas pour
vous mais elle en tout cas céit évident
pour valeriniqu quel est l'évolution des
conditions des
auicour depuis la prise de conscience
mondiale et la reconnaissance en gé de
nombreux gouvernements mais en fait
comme comme vous l'avez
raconté parfois les films et cette prise
de conscience ça agace Pékin qui veut
aller contre ce qu'ils appellent la
propagande à l'extérieur et qui peut
éventuellement libérer des
personnalités pour essayer de démontrer
que ce que fait la Chine au sang c'est
complètement normal et c'est pas du tout
un génocide comme on le dit mais en
réalité pour l'ensemble de la population
Ouigour les choses ne se sont pas
vraiment
amélioré la politique de répression
continue la mise en camp continue est-ce
que nous à notre échelle nous ici depuis
la France on peut faire quelque chose
partager l'info moi je pense si plus
tous ceux qui sont dans la politique les
présidents les journalistes tout ça qui
peuvent faire quelque chose bien sr
parce que nous on est que des collégi
dans collège on peut juste partager
l'info avec eu je rebondis sur ce que tu
venais de dire les gouvernements la
politique il s'avère que le 20 janvier
2022 la France a reconnu euh le génocide
ougour a reconnu voilà ce qui se passait
là-bas
euh est-ce que ça est-ce que ça peut
aider ça est-ce que est-ce que c'est le
genre de démarche qui qui est utile que
les députés de l'Assemblée nationale
reconnaissent un génocide là-bas au
xingang c'est quoi c'est des mots c'est
des mots jetés en l'air ou c'est oui
Bintou moi je trouve que ça suffit pas
faudrait que tout le monde soit du même
avis pour que on SAU des Ouigours
d'accord vous qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé vous éc Dar de cette
reconnaissance du génocide Ouigours pour
les ougours c'est très important c'est
symbolique surtout d'un d'un pays comme
la France qui a une aura énorme en terme
de droit de l'homme à l'international
non c'est très important mais vous
pouvez faire quelque chose au quotidien
de très très concret c'est exactement là
où je voulais les amener alors vous
pensez à quoi à ce que vous portez
est-ce que vous savez que les Ouigours
sont utilisés comme esclaves pour
fabriquer des vêtements des chaussures
de très grandes marques que vous
certainement vous portez sur vous
aujourd'hui il existe des sites internet
vous pouvez très facilement retrouver
les marques qui font qui utilisent le
travail forcé des ougours pour produire
leur leurs produits ça peut être des des
chaussures des baskets bien sûr ça peut
être des t-shirts des
pantalons si vous faites ça le boycotte
c'està-dire que si vous plutôt
qu'achetez une marque vous allez en
choisir une autre qui fait pas
travailler les ougour à la fin les
marques vont le savoir et vont dire
c'est pas pour le bien des ougours ils
vont juste se dire on fait moins
d'argent donc on va arrêter de faire ça
ça vous pouvez le faire c'est hyper
simple vous allez le faire
ouais qu'est-ce que vous venez de
comprendre il faut éviter d'acheter
toute chose créé ou fait par les Ig
exactement Bintou on continue avec toi
question pour Valérie Nick dans la
géopolitique mondiale actuelle et
l'implication des États-Unis quelle est
la position de la Russie vis-à-vis du
génnocide igour alors en fait comme vous
avz entendu dire sans doute à la radio à
la télévision surtout depuis l'Ukraine
il y a un vrai rapprochement entre la
Russie et la Chine donc la Russie ne ne
critique pas beaucoup le ce qui se passe
au stiang mais quand même derrière ces
positions là qui sont réelles et qui se
sont encore plus fortes de depuis la
guerre en Ukraine l'alliance entre la
Chine et la Russie il y a aussi des
différences de fond euh parce que en
fait le le sang et la population du sang
je vous vous parlais tout à l'heure du
du turquestan oriental quand ça
s'appelait comme ça jusqu'à ce que
jusqu'à 1949 et bien en fait ça fait
partie de cette zone d'influence russe
traditionnelle qui est l'Asie centrale
donc il y a toutes les républiques comme
le Kazakhstan
l'oubékistan donc qui sont qui sont
indépendantes maintenant mais qui
étaient assez proche de la Russie et
donc je pense qu'en Russie il y a une
certaine ambigué et il faut quand même
rajouter qu'il y a aussi une alliance ça
s'appelle l'Organisation de coopération
de shanghï qui date des années 2000 pour
faire simple et où la Russie et la Chine
en théorie coopèent pour lutter contre
ce qu'ils appelle le séparatisme ça
c'est les Chinois qui ont imposé en fait
cette clause là et l'idée pour Pékin
c'est d'obtenir évidemment un soutien
ferme de Moscou pour sa politique au
stiang manel on t'écoute pour Valérie
Nick pourquoi les différents
gouvernement n'en fut pas
plus et bien en fait en faire plus ça
veut dire par exemple décider des
sanctions contre le régime chinois qui
pourrait pousser Pékin à être à prendre
en compte les reproches qui lui sont
faits euh c'est difficile parce que
chacun a ses intérêts économiques on
voit bien que même avec la Russie
aujourd'hui c'est difficile de faire des
sanctions d'une manière unifiée et donc
il y a toujours des man des moyens de
contourner les sanctions donc les moyens
de pression sur la Chine sont assez
limité et en fait dans le temps les
Chinois même le gouvernement chinois qui
n' qui était le même en terme de
principe était peut-être parfois un peu
plus sensible à l'image qu'il donnait à
l'étranger il voulait séduire montrer
que la Chine était une puissance qui
n'était pas agressive y compris contre
sa propre population ou contre les
Ouigours ces minorités mais aujourd'hui
avec sitingping le nouveau président
enfin le nouveau président depuis 2012
et bien on a l'impression que la Chine
se fiche en fait de l'image qu'elle
projette à l'étranger qu'elle donne
qu'elle se veut très puissante et
qu'elle refuse de tenir compte en fait
des critiques la Chine pourrait-elle
faire ce qu'elle fait avec les Ouigours
avec une autre communauté comme les
tibétas benah en fait elle a ce qu'elle
fait qu'on avec les Ouigours elle l'a
fait aussi dans le passé avec les
Tibétains pour les mêmes raisons les
Tibétains ont une très forte identité
culturelle ils ont une religion enfin
ils sont bouddhistes mais enfin la
religion occupe une place très
importante au Tibet alors et tibétains
ont été totalement submergés au Tibet
par la population ran qui s'installe et
donc ils deviennent minoritaires dans
leur propre région il y a une répression
très forte les les les religieux sont
très fortement réprimés notamment pour
les empêcher d'avoir une influence la
grosse différence entre les Ouigours et
les Tibétains c'est que les Tibétains
ont une une image une représentation
dans la personne du Dalai Lama dont vous
avez peut-être déjà entendu parler qui
est le chef
religieux au Tibet qui et qui donc lui
est réfugié en Inde Adam Salah et donc
en fait au Tibet il a ça s'est
personnalisé autour de la personnalité
du Dalai Lama o les Ouigours n'ont pas à
ma connaissance une représentation aussi
symboliquement forte que celle-là donc
ça peut-être nuit aussi à la prise en
compte de leur cause vous parlez des
Ouigours qui vivent à l'étranger il y en
a qui vivent en France aussi euh si s'il
tombe sur ce cette émission sur vos
questions sur vos réflexions qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez leur dire qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez leur transmettre comme
message Bintou moi je voudrais leur dire
courage enfin un jour j'espère que ça se
terminera et faut pas lâcher euh qu'on
les soutient qu'il sont pas tout seul
essayer de les aider en partageant
l'info
HM et comme quoi leur histoire est
entendue ce sont des survivants ouais à
essayer de
de comment dire ça de moins porter des
vêtements de marque et les aider pour
plus qu'il travaille l qui continue à
témoigner comme ça pour que les choses
changent
leors témoignage il est important aussi
pour qu'on pour que vous et qu'on puisse
collectivement se rendre compte de la
situation là-bas Nathan ils doivent
tenir bon
pour pour que quelqu'un un jour
essayer de les faire sortir de la prison
euh juste avant de juste avant de nous
quitter je voulais signaler l'édition de
cette de cette bande dessinée que vous
avez écrite avec un dessinateur
évidemment voilà c'est un ouvrage qui
permet de revenir évidemment sur bah sur
ce qu'on voit dans le documentaire mais
d'approfondir aussi certaines choses et
peut-être d'apporter aussi une autre
grille de lecture on en fait don au CDI
si ça vous va Eric darbr voilà on vous
laisse on vous laisse pour vous
évidemment vous connaissez maintenant
bien le bien le sujet n'hésitez pas
parler à vos à vos camarades pour qu'il
s'intéressent aussi à la situation des
Ouigours à travers le documentaire que
vous avez vu évidemment mais aussi à
travers cette bande dessinée qu'on
laisse dans votre dans votre CDI voilà
l'émission elle est déjà terminée merci
infiniment à vous deux d'y avoir
participer merci à vous les élèves de 3e
du collège le Luzard d'avoir aussi bien
travaillé d'avoir posé autant de
questions on remercie aussi votre
professeur qui vous a extrêmement bien
préparé pour pour cette émission et non
on se retrouve très vite avec un nouveau
documentaire et une nouvelle classe
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour
questionner le monde et ses images allez
salut les élèves au revoir
[Musique]
salut franchement c'est
super plus
beau